hello everybody my name is markiplier
and Merry Christmas to everyone out
there I'm gonna be doing a quiz here
that is very specifically curtailed to
Christmas and asking you if you are
ready for Christmas so shall we begin
how full is your jingle cave it's barren
without hope pray for my jingle cave I'm
trying so hard but my humble jingle cave
remains an embarrassment it is a healthy
amount of full my Belle look good my
grotto bursts with Christmas cheer if it
were any fuller the geese would
suffocate and the tinsel would melt and
the bells would explode like shrapnel
causing a great disturbance well I mean
judging by my jingle cave here I don't
even have my lights up oh man it is
barren without hope pray for bud
pray for Mojang hashtag pray for marks
jingle key what Christmas mantra do you
say over and over every day at sundown
until you are dismissed follow the star
retrieve them follow the star retrieve
the baby follow the star retrieve the
baby follow the star retrieve the baby
the breath of Donner sustains me I
breathe it every day
no enemy shall prosper my Christmas is
too strong I'm a good I'm a good little
Christmas [ __ ] I live in a good little
Christmas ooh how robust are your
Christmas fantasies they are not very
robust they are somewhat robust but they
do not keep me from fulfilling my
obligations to my job and family very
robust I am rarely cognizant of the
reality around me the fantasies are on
all consuming fire swallowing me beyond
escape I am now Christmas and Christmas
is me I'd go very robust because I'm
always cognizant of the reality
to be rarely oh no wait no I'm never I'm
never cognizant of reality around to be
when the tired virgin is wheeled to your
home on Christmas Eve who will you
impersonate to make her clap I don't I
don't like the fact that I read that
sentence frosty the human soul caged in
a walking snow prison Ralphie the boy
who shoots his fix off with a gun Grinch
the green mound hurts bear Polar Express
the long metal snake who takes children
far away from their families I gotta be
the Polar Express I guess oh that's
horrible but I love it unto which list
has the red jacket man carved your
family's name the less than 20 mortal
sins list the more than 20 mortal sins
list the list of perfect obedience to
red jacket man the commendable well if
there's one thing that they can say
about me I do not have commendable
hygiene I'm gonna I'm gonna guess that
I'm on the more than 20 mortal sins list
if there's one thing you know about
markiplier is that I have many many
mortal sins to my name which of the
merry morsels do you feed your family
the Turtledove chard black on a metal
skewer ooh delicious
the omelet stuffed with mentos ooh
disgusting the festive gristle I do not
feed my family merry morsels that I do
not I do not do that although I do like
me a festive you've unlocked the super
clicker badge
ah I'm gonna go with the gristle wreath
nah yes no yes no yes no yes no yes no
yes no yes okay when the Red Jacket man
is in your house how will you make him
go away I have no plan yet ice will
threatened sawed off the horns of his
pets shake Oh fearsome rattle I will
hide with my family in the crawl space
until he's finished I will shake
my fearsome baby rattle and he shall
quiver as my rattle whatever I'm gonna
die probably does a red jacket man could
you possibly believe anymore if you try
yes there's doubt inside me and it
brings me shame no I have taken all my
vows my belief is pristine I would
gladly die for Christmas I decline to
answer this question probably you know
if there's truth to be told I have doubt
inside me and it brings me shame every
day every day good results you are not
oh no no no no what are you thinking are
you crazy
tis the season don't you realize tis the
season you're letting everyone down my
jingle oh Christmas and there you have
it
Christmas I'm not ready I don't think
this is enough but it's all I have
so thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you for joining me on
this quiz what's your Christmas spirit
spirit like I'll put this quiz down in
the comments button oh I'll put it down
somewhere find it I've hidden it hidden
it away you'll never find it it's
somewhere down there but if you find it
I don't think you're ready for it so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]